you found out the three trait the three
most common traits of Highly Successful
People do you remember those yeah it was
um it's so funny
superiority complex so the three most
common traits of hyper successful people
that they looked at and it was
interesting because there's
the influencer world wants to be like
you have to wake up at five or you have
to do cold plungers or whatever the [__]
right but the thing that but there was
actually very few that they all had in
common so number one was that they had a
superiority complex they thought they
were better than other people and that
they deserved more
the second is that they suffered from
massive insecurity and feeling that they
would never be enough
and third they had impulse control
and so you've got this combination of
people who are like I want to do this
big thing so this big toward thing and
they've got this big away pain that's
like I'm never gonna be enough I always
have to do more and then they have
impulse control that keeps them focused
on the goal
without seeing the woman in the red
dress or getting pursued by her and that
like
so it's like shoot High have a big thing
that that motivate like have a big tiger
behind you and stay on the path have you
ever heard uh Jordan Peterson talk about
that study of starving rats in a tube
with a spring attached to them no
[__] brilliant this is this is what
you're talking about so
um starving rats are placed into a tube
yeah and they have a spring that is
attached to the tail that can measure
the force that they pull out and that's
a proxy for desire then they waft the
smell of cheese in from the front of the
tube and the rat poles and they measure
how hard they want to go and you think
these rats are starving they'll be
pulling pretty hard then they do another
iteration of the study this time they
waft the smell of cheese in from the
front but they waft the smell of a cat
in from behind and the Rats pull harder
yeah and what's the lesson that you'd
not only need to run towards something
that you want yeah but you need to run
away from something that you fear yeah
the problem and this is I like super
superiority complex crippling insecurity
impulse control right I like that
the problem is
the people who we admire the most due to
the most success in the real world
don't necessarily have the most
admirable internal states that to me
isn't necessarily the most peaceful
Blissful way to live your life what does
it say that especially in the modern
world we uh Revere the people who have
external accolades of success and yet
the three most common traits of these
super successful people lead from a
place which is almost objectively
miserable
unadmirable yeah how do we how do we
Square this circle I think it's just
what are we solving for
so
um like I mean a lot of people I love
watching Last Dance which is Michael
Jordan's you know mini docu-series
phenomenal yeah unbelievable
um I think most people could see him
there and be like I don't know if I
really Envy this guy's life like he
still seems like pretty upset despite
being a billionaire despite all the you
know these these these other things and
so I think that if like what are we
solving for like my my closest friend Dr
Kashi he has a statement because he
coached Olympic uh Olympic teams and he
was like Champions are broken
I was like huh he's like they people
look at Champions and try and find
something that that champion has that
they don't have he's like but it's not
that at all he's like they lack
something everyone else has which is an
off button they just don't stop
and
at the end of the day like
if we're if we're optimizing for
outcomes then the most broken person
will win the person who has the absolute
biggest you know desire for achievement
the absolute biggest fear or pain that
they're running away from and the
hardest impulse control now impulse
control most people would agree is a
good thing the other two not as much
and so
what are we optimizing for what problem
are we solving it's my favorite it's
probably the number one most frequently
Asked question that I asked to our
portfolio companies whenever we're about
to do anything which is what problem are
we solving if the problem that we're
solving is that I want to be content
well there's a lot of ways to do that
you don't need to do all these other
things if the problem you're solving is
that you want to be the richest man in
the world
well you're going to have to have a lot
of spirit accomplished you have a lot of
crippling insecurity and you have a lot
of impulse control and you have to wait
a long time
there's a quote from Jason Pagan that
says accept all of your heroes are full
of [__] Your Heroes aren't Gods they're
just regular people who probably got
good at One Thing by neglecting
literally everything else
yeah I just I agree with the statement
[__] money um I it's just so
interesting to me I've been thinking
about this to do with Billy McFarland uh
let me let me just get this in hit it
and that's okay
because if they wanted that then that's
the problem that they're solving for
like I get criticized all the time for
work-life balance people are like well
you don't have any hobbies Alex and you
don't whatever right and I'm like I
don't [__] want any
so why do I have to sacrifice things
that I would prefer to do to do things I
don't want to do to satisfy your
objective measure of what you deem as
work-life balance
why so that's what this is what you were
talking about uh was it optimized for
the outcome or what's the metric of
success uh yeah he was saying like what
is it that people are optimizing for
right
it seems to me that
you have stepped back and decided
axiomatically this is the thing that I'm
optimizing for that I enjoy most doing
yes that's I enjoy playing the game and
so everything I do is about the game yes
my podcast is called the game I draw
pictures all day about business I write
books about business I make content
about businesses I've never seen a
picture of 200 million offers a zillion
pictures in there oh are they done by
you 100 all of the drawings are mine and
100 leads is like 100 Doodles in it are
you doing good are they nice I think so
are they are they cute yeah they've got
little animals in yeah they don't have
animals and I'm not I'm not going to
look at them oh there's there's little
bag of money big bag of money like
that's how nice dead serious sweet but
no but like and and I spend the rest of
my day doing business
and so it's like
why don't you Garden because I don't
care here's the other thing right I I
always talk about this Steffi Graf um
they one of the greatest female tennis
players of all time and she gets tested
when she's 10 years old 11 years old and
she's in some tennis academy and they
engage the players on two criteria they
gauge them on desire to train
uh and skill set all right and she was
10 out of 10 on both so okay not only
has she got the raw materials to make a
phenomenal tennis player but she'll
outwork you and to her it won't even
feel like work that's [__] terrifying
yeah and that's why I do think for the
people that look at yourself and say uh
Alex is on a road to burn out it's
because you are using your theory of
mind about how you would feel if you had
to work as much as you do but okay what
is the thing that you can do longer than
anybody else and to them it looks like
working to you it looks like play or
feels like play what would that be oh
well for me it would be uh computer
games or knitting or rock music or
whatever okay so imagine if you've just
got to do that all day but instead of it
being rock music it was [__] business
yeah someone commented the other day um
was it you're sprinting on a treadmill
uh they were concerned that the pace
that the show is going out at was going
to cause me to burn out and in
retrospect I'm you know in five years
time I'm like oh [__] yeah I was moving
too quick but I don't think I don't
think that like
I work at the pace that I like to work
at and I also like to see where those
limits are and that's exciting to me to
go okay just how much harder can I go
here and then again you've got to temper
it with that's burnout like that's just
the beginning of it and you only know
that after you've burned out like 30
times uh but that's it's trite to say
after atomic Habits by James clear right
but the intersection of like what you
love to do what you're good at and what
you can be paid for is like slap bang in
the middle of it
we'll get back to talking to Alex in one
second but first I need to tell you
about HubSpot 28 of some people's weeks
are spent reading deleting and sorting
emails which means that very much email
is not dead starting an email newsletter
means that you've got direct connection
with your audience it means that you
actually own your audience it is the
only way that you can own them without
going through a third party like a
social media platform and from HubSpot
right now you can download their free
email template that will teach you how
to make your own newsletter you can
learn how to build an amazing email
newsletter from scratch that will check
out a compiled lookbook of awesome
examples from real Publications you can
learn what it takes to create a
successful email newsletter with
exceptional design unique and compelling
copy clickable calls to action and
excellent user experience and there is a
step-by-step guide about how to get your
newsletter launched so if you've been
thinking I want to start doing a
newsletter this sounds cool this sounds
like a good way for me to start writing
to build an audience that I can then
sell to or I can then move to other
platforms as well this is a fantastic
place to begin all that you need to do
to download download this free guide
that will take you from no email
newsletter to a fantastically designed
email newsletter using industry inside
information all that you need to do is
head to
clickhubspot.com Modern wisdom that's
click hubspot.com modern wisdom to
download your free email template today
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
foreign
[Music]